anyway here with reaction South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham is here Senator I
can only think of three outcomes here
number one he's covering for himself in
terms of not uh pursuing the law to its
fullest in the hunter Biden probe he's
covering for his boss Merrick Garland
the AG or he knew damn well Hunter Biden
was guilty as hell and he was making an
excuse to the IRS professionals that
knew that in fact he didn't pay his
taxes uh you tell me which one is it
likely to be and I'll add one last thing
I thought Democrats love whistleblowers
they're going to call all six of the
liars
well here's uh
hello by the way it's been a while since
I've seen you I hope you're welcome
welcome back Senator thank you thank you
very much so this is an important moment
here uh here's what I can tell you
without any doubt when it comes to the
Department of Justice I don't trust them
they got to come forward under oath and
testify so here's what The Whistleblower
has said the group of whistleblowers
that Hunter Biden got the benefit of the
doubt unlike anybody they've ever seen
and they've been there for decades that
every time there was a question it it
wound up being in Hunter Biden's favor
they claimed that Mr Weiss the U.S
attorney from Delaware salt special
counsel status and was denied that
status and that he wanted to bring
charges in D.C and California but he was
told no so what did I do I wrote Mr
Weiss and said what's the deal here did
you ask for special counsel status he
told me in the letter he had a
discussion about it but he was sure he
could get it if he needed it and he
never really answered the question the
second thing that he said in the letter
back to me was he never went to D.C or
California for more serious charges he
was never rebuffed by those
jurisdictions but here's the big one I
asked him about the 1023 remember the
1023 report if it had not been for
Center Grassley we would never known
that there was an accusation that Hunter
and Joe Biden both were involved in a
bribery Scandal involving barisma the
giant uh gas company uh in Ukraine that
twin 1023 investigative report was found
by uh Senator Grassley it was redacted
he got the redactions lifted and we now
know a credible source for the FBI
literally on their payroll claims that
there were conversations up to 15
between Hunter and Joe Biden regarding a
gas company official in the Ukraine
here's what Mr wise said I cannot tell
you about that accusation because as
part of a criminal investigation that's
one of two things that they're still
looking at Hunter Biden for additional
charges what I I don't believe that they
don't want to tell me what happened to
the 1023 investigation and I can tell
your audience you're all going to know
what happened they sweep it under the
rug that they investigate and find out
it was fraudulent I want to know what
happened to the accusations regarding
Hunter Biden Joe biding taking bribes in
Ukraine I did not get that answer in
this letter I'm not going to stop until
I found out to find out how that
accusation was disposed of Senator I
would believe that the people that
Hunter was in touch with during all this
time period National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan Secretary of State Lincoln
the wife of blinken the head of the
pandemic response covid-19 Kathy Chung
serving as the pentagon's deputy of
director of protocols Biden's executive
assistant at the time Ron Clane is
another one the communications director
for Jill Biden and and the list goes on
I want all of them put under old Senator
and I want to know what they know no
knew and when they knew it I want their
emails I want their text messages and I
think that information Nation will shed
a lot of light on the fact that those
whistleblowers I have every belief in my
heart mind and soul they're telling the
truth and it's interesting that nobody
in the media is cares about
whistleblowers anymore because they love
the one hearsay whistleblower
non-whistleblower uh that talked about
Donald Trump in Ukraine
well here's what's funny they took the
answer to my letter by Mr Weiss to say
case closed I wrote the letter I didn't
get an answer about what Mr Weiss did
regarding the 1023 investigation about
Hunter and Joe Biden potentially taking
bribes in Ukraine he didn't answer that
question here's what I do know that I
don't trust the system to tell me the
truth I want to know what happened who
did you talk to to do to dismiss the
allegation how did you dispose of this
allegation and I do know this for a
thousand percent for sure that the FBI
and other department of justice
officials briefed Mr Weiss and his team
about the 1023 they were told by other
people in the Department of Justice this
is not Russian disinformation you need
to look at it
Senator we've got to get to the bottom
of it I think we're getting closer to
the truth every day I do too and I think
six people uh that will say the same
thing are going to be very compelling
can't wait to hear them all talk you
were right about the Russian hoax and
you're going to be right about this I
smell right here I think I'm going to be
right now Family Syndicate as well I
just have a good feeling about it anyway
Senator Graham we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else